still war es plötzlich im wald von
würenlingen totenstill
an den ästen hängen kleider fetzen am
boden lagen wrackteile
dazwischen das was von menschen übrig
bleibt wenn ein flugzeug abstürzt
es ist der 21 februar 1970 eine bombe
explodiert an bord des swissair 330 auf
dem flug von zürich nach tel aviv
copilot arme mädchen funkt an den tower
in zürich
47 menschen ermordet der grausige
höhepunkt einer terrorwelle mit dessen
hintergründen sich ein neues buch
befasst
wann endlich beginnt bei euch der kampf
gegen die heilige kuh israel lautet der
provokante und irritierende titel
es ist ein zitat aus einem brief von
dieter conzelmann einer der kultfiguren
der 68er bewegung politclown rasch
rebell und sprachrohr der kommune 1 in
berlin
das buch des politikwissenschaftlers
wolfgang kraushaar
selbst alt 68er beschreibt wie radikale
rebellen zu kampfgenossen
palästinensischer terroristen wurden die
teile der generation die gegen ihre nazi
väter protestierten
gleichzeitig begannen gewalt gegen juden
zu dulden oder auszuleben
ein tabubruch damals wie heute
man hat das ja zunächst mal gar nicht
für möglich gehalten dass aus dieser
gruppe von leuten heraus bestimmte
personen dann auch im untergrund gehen
würden und terroristische anschläge
verüben können das hat man ja nicht für
möglich gehalten
und insofern ist natürlich die
ernüchterung darüber besonders groß
und das erzeugt abwehrreflexe man will
das wirklich nicht wahrhaben
wolfgang kraushaar das buch ist eine
verstörende chronik der jahre 1970 bis
72 ein puzzle von ereignissen und
indizien wie zeigen wie sich der
antiimperialismus von teilen der
protestbewegung verbündet mit dem
protest gegen die politik israels
und schließlich in antisemitismus
umschlägt
wie aus parolen aktionen werden
wie palästinensische terroristen hand in
hand mit deutschen unterstützern eine
blutspur durch deutschland und die
schweiz ziehen die in würenlingen ihren
höhepunkt findet es ist wirklich ein
qualitativer sprung gewesen wofür der
flugzeugabsturz in würenlingen steht
weil zum ersten mal eine zivile maschine
durch eine paketbombe zum absturz
gebracht worden ist zuvor hat es zwar
schon entführungen seitens der
palästinenser gegeben aber das ist
wirklich eine neue eskalationsstufe
nämlich personen auslöschen zu wollen
das heißt nicht einfach nur ein anschlag
mit möglicherweise blutigen konsequenzen
sondern wirklich leute unmittelbar zu
tode bringen zu wollen
55 tote in elf tagen in deutsch
palästinensischen zusammenarbeit der
erste am 10 februar 1972 am flughafen
münchen als palästinenser eine el al
maschine entführen wollen
drei tage später ein anschlag auf ein
wohnhaus der jüdischen gemeinde in
münchen
sieben bewohner darunter
holocaust-überlebende verbrennen
der brandsatz stammt vermutlich von
deutschen genossen am 21 februar
explodiert eine bombe an bord einer
karabel der austrian airlines auf dem
flug nach tel aviv
die maschine kann in frankfurt notlanden
drei stunden später hören ling die
bombenbauer sind schnell ermittelt
werden in deutschland wo die paketbombe
aufgegeben wurde verhaftet verhört
und wieder freigelassen bis heute gab es
kein gerichtsverfahren
weder deutschland noch die schweiz
zeigten großes interesse die täter zur
verantwortung zu ziehen
angst vor weiteren anschlägen was die
hintergründe dieser passivität sind das
will der journalist otto hostettler
herausfinden er hat in den akten zum
fall würenlingen recherchiert die
teilweise nach wie vor geheim gehalten
werden
warum war die schweiz so passiv
künftigen anschlägen vermutet wird stark
und mutig dass verschiedene große
europäische airlines zahlung geleistet
hat verschiedene organisationen
terroristische berlin
das ist sehr traurig gemacht hat es geht
tatsächlich dass dort das ist der tag
des ganges sollten airlines sich
freikaufen von terroristischen
anschlägen
wer waren die komplizen der täter wer
die hintermänner 43 jahre danach stellt
dieses buch unangenehme fragen schreibt
geschichte neu und lässt nicht vergessen
was damals geschah im wald von
würenlingen